[Music]
Zach I've been in the world with you you
and I hang we're pals
let's just get that out there as if that
were true and but I've noticed that
women go absolutely crazy for you and
Adam I'm thinking less so
I was less so is it is it is it tough to
hang out was that I don't consider
myself like an ugly person but I am a
true treasure troll next to next to you
I feel like I should just I should do
something similar to your hair and put a
little jewel in my bellybutton and be a
treasure troll and live under a bridge
and collect it all yeah I might make
similar amounts of cash so cute you have
no idea how handsome you are
oh you're very good-looking very
good-looking guy
so what's it really like let's say you
guys go to some place let's say you go
to dinner together or something what's
it weird Kazak his fans range from like
twelve-year-old girls to like 65
year-old women and they're all sexually
attracted to him and it's the weirdest
is like these like the old late like the
ladies that are like could be our mom's
age who are like there's no place safe
for him he's not famous well who say to
those women I died I don't know I do not
much I I don't know it's uh the moms can
be crazier sometimes than the kids
I think either in a way they're more
aggressive you know then they've been
around the block yeah well they're
they're older have a stroke as you said
that
Oh around ready to be creepy oh yeah
that was my creepy old guy impression oh
okay all right
I don't know I'm not I'm not an
impression but it's very funny because
uh because as much as my fans come
around Adam has just as many and they're
awesome and I'm getting to meet them but
they're very different um so it's kind
of like West Side Story every time they
come together like yeah there's like the
Sharks and the Jets yeah all of that
would be like all these girls and
there's like Adams fans yeah all these
like cute girls who just want to take
photos with Zach and then mine that are
just supplied with like beer bongs and
the bonbons those kind of bomb
[Applause]
you